all right
we are going to interrupt our regularly
scheduled retrospective on x-men and
talk about the
dexter series finale now i would have
had this video out
a little sooner to run the thing
actually aired except that when i first
tried to sit down and talk about the
thing
what the f so you know i took a few days
calmed down came back to try again
so i've let things simmer down
for a little bit and i'm gonna give it
another go
talking about the dexter's here
if you couldn't tell i was not exactly a
fan
it should be obvious that i'm gonna be
delving pretty heavily
into spoilers on this thing it's hard to
even know where to start
i'm gonna try and confine as much as i
can to
the series finale itself but i am gonna
have to talk
a little bit about the season leading up
to it so let's get that stuff out of the
way first
season eight has a couple of inherent
problems
the first is is that season two of
dexter really should have been the last
season
now when i say that i'm not saying they
should have stopped making more dexter
after the second season
what i'm saying is the feel of season
two
is what the feel of a final season
should have been for that show if you
don't remember
there was no season long serial killer
that dexter was hunting down
he was the killer and everybody was
closing in on him
oh my god they're gonna catch him that
should have been the feeling
for the final season another thing this
season have working against him this is
going to factor in more directly with
the
last episode is hannah mckay because the
idea
that dexter abandons harrison to
hannah mckay just seems
wrong here's the thing dexter may have
been a killer he may have
sort of been a magnet for all sorts of
dangerous stuff and he may have even
been
right in terms of he would always
endanger the people around him but at
least he knew how to function in society
hannah never really seems to have that
her solution to every problem she ever
has
is to poison it that's even how she
tries to get
dexter's attention when she wants his
help
what the heck is she gonna do the first
time harrison as a teenager
brings home a girl that she doesn't like
and then there's
deb i can't decide if i have an inherent
issue with deb dying or not
i do have an issue with how they did it
in terms of just
how it was portrayed and then how dexter
reacted which was just
weird he takes her body out and dumps it
in the ocean like he had done to all of
his victims
what in the hell is he doing and then
of course there's dexter himself now i
can just barely
go with the idea that he has come to the
conclusion
that he will always be a danger to those
around him and that he feels it's safest
to leave those people that he loves
behind i can kind of go with that
but it's still an inherently
unsatisfying thing for him to be doing
because he's been dealing with this
question in this issue
it's a legitimate fear but the idea that
he battled that
for eight seasons ultimately to just
give in
to that fear and say heck with it i'm
leaving
is supremely unsatisfying and it makes
him come across
as weak he basically gave up the fight
then we add in the whole thing with the
whole lumberjack thing which first of
all is weird in the first damn place
second of all there had just been some
hint that he was still
killing that you know his kill tools on
that table
something anything because if he's not
going to embrace
that dark passenger side of himself what
was the point of abandoning everybody
it's like they tried to make him a
martyr but all they really did was make
him a wuss
but you know what here's the thing all
of that all of those things are problems
they're
issues but it's the feel of the episode
it does not feel like dexter it feels
like
they wrote this thing handed it over to
a director and a crew
who had never seen an episode of dexter
in
their lives the beating heart
of dexter as a show has always been
tension the tension of him
hunting his next kill the tension that
maybe he's going to get caught
the tension that maybe he will get
killed on those occasions
when they had a really worthy adversary
for him it's always been about the
tension and there is almost
no tension whatsoever in the way this
final episode is presented
there's a split second where it starts
to feel like dexter again and that's
when dexter is sitting across from saxon
says
i'm gonna kill you with that pen for for
about
five seconds like oh and that's that's
the only fleeting moment and the rest of
it the thing just sort of
meanders about and not even tying up
loose ends i'm not even sure what it is
this episode is doing
because the actual events that had to be
wrapped up
get wrapped up by about the halfway mark
and then everything after that is just
what the
what what what is this i've
seen a lot of final episodes
but i have never ever
in my life an episode so completely
disappointing and disconnected from
everything that came before it maybe
once the rage comes down it'll be sort
of a fascinating case study
but i tell you right now
i got nothing on that
nihilistic little note this council
has adjourned